et bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur des
gones activé dans mon studio parisienne
pour commenter ce championnat du monde
anand topalov avec jérôme mots phrases
bonjour jérôme bonjour stéphane alors
première partie et percute chaos
attendent au tapis annoncé au tapis mais
les arbitres ne peut pas encore compter
jusqu'à dix ont réuni jusqu'à 12 puisque
il ya douze parties de ce parti il a le
temps de se refaire un la limite il vaut
mieux être surpris d'entrée et avoir le
temps de se refaire que d'être surpris à
la 11e partie eder le couteau sous la
gorge
on va voir comment on va réagir à cette
situation en 12 parties non ça veut dire
que quand il est parti du conte moitié
pour avoir des 2000 points
le premier cas si ces demies gagne est
sûr d'être champion du monde
voilà et en cas d'égalité il ya des des
partage en partie rapide on avait quand
même des départageant blitz il est
partagé en partie rapide devenait
voilà c'est un tir au but du tir au but
voilà c'est ça ça peut arriver mais sa
peur et qu'on espère qu'on n'en arrivera
pas là c'est quand même mieux d'avoir un
match qui se finit disons dans le temps
de jeu c'est un peu comme au foot oui où
les penaltys vos remarques ça peut être
ça peut être assez cas des souvenirs
contrastés
voilà c'est toujours plus contrastée et
puis c'est un peu toujours la loterie
alors deuxième partie donc à nantes
s'est fait mettre ko d'entrée quand même
dans cette première partie puisque au
24e compliments il était quasiment foutu
donc c'est très important de voir
comment on va réagir dans cette 2e ou là
les blancs face à un taux à leur très
remonté qui joue chez lui devant son
public qui en plus est un joueur
d'attaqué donc doit être gonflé à bloc
par cette première victoire à nantes par
mal la deuxième on espère qu'il va pas
sombrer parce que ça peut arriver aussi
ko d'entrée donc on y va avec cette
deuxième partie du match
allende se topalov un homme donc je ne
peux vous dire c'est 15e champion du
monde face à tampa l'ofs
le bulgare son challenger donc on y va
avec vichy qui démarre par des cadres
bon alors on sait qu alain dejoux
d'abord soit des 490 fernand donc ya pas
de preuve dont il a choisi des cas est
ce que c'est un choix là aussi deux
matchs où c'est ce que si un choix je
dirais opportuniste on va voir ça et
notamment mais on pourra dire mais
qu'après le match si c'était un match
d'ouverture déterminée ou ou si les
joueurs vont tenter plein de choses
c'est plutôt des joueurs surtout topalov
qui est capable de tenter plein de trucs
et pas de jouer une seule ouverture on y
va khalef si ça va
topalov répond le même coup qu'à nantes
à la première donc ça c'est fait c4est
l'a donc dans la première évidemment on
a vu à nantes là les jouets g6 la
topalov choisi une autre possibilité il
joue de 6,6 alors qu'il peut transposer
soit dans une gangue vidame soit suivant
après quand on joue les blancs avec le
pool b 4
des variantes autres on va voir sa
carrière trois donc déjà un homme ne
sort pas cavalier donc qui permet pas
fondées 4 déjà c'est un premier signe
des cercles donc l'apparition perdant
chacun ici trois rentrerez dans une
gangue biden classique et il choisit g3
catalan
donc ça ses larmes favorite de kramnik
celui qui l'a battu pour devenir
champion du monde attendent donc
cramique joué beaucoup g3 donc c'est une
une ouverture typique des champions du
monde aussi ce coup j'ai trois des
princes et 4 ça c'est classique et noir
bombay en profite parce que comme on
veut mettre le fond j'ai deux prendre
ces quatre on s'assure que le fou de
prendre à penser car il faudra prendre
le pion soit avait la dame avec échec
d'en prendre soin par d'autres moyens
plus tard voire même avoir des
difficultés à le prendre parce que aussi
c'est un pion qu'on peut lâcher en
contrepartie les bla en deux pions au
centre voyez ici qui ont eu 2 et des
cartes donc ils peuvent lâcher ce pion
autant que possible longtemps et puis
plus tard pourquoi pas avoir une
majorité centrale de pions qui peut
s'avérer aussi menaçante
alors on va voir la suite rouge et de 30
clients ne se pressent pas alors à noter
ainsi les noirs joué le coup par exemple
b5 pour protéger ces quatre là bas et
blanc pourrait tenter même des coups
comme à 404 quatre cavaliers 5,15 le 5
mai pape à 4 d'abord je pense parce que
sur à 4 imaginons un groupe comme ces
six pions brand et sur ses preuves et 5
maintenant qu avait 5 ans a obligé les
noirs jouer décalé des scènes puisque
s'il n'ya plus possibilité de défendre
cette diagonale donc il faudrait jouer
avec le cavalier des 5 et de 4 gagnera
un temps un but n'a rien su des
possibilités pas forcément les meilleurs
coups mais c'est pour donner des idées
donc là les noirs choses regarder à 6
donc ça c'est important pour baic
préparer le coup des cinq plus tard on
pas forcément pour jouer tout de suite
mais par exemple maintenant les blancs
peuvent plus jouer damas quatre échecs
des cinq attaques la dame la dame bouche
et ensuite on joue torah cette nounou
fou mais c est plutôt fondées c'est
d'ailleurs et on ne peut éventuellement
penser à garder le pion et on vers le
bio on en parle plus on s'accroche aux
pions et un double enjeu maintien de
plus très ferme et très difficile à
reprendre
donc à 25 de la part des blancs
classique regard des cavaliers 5
simplement mais j'attaque le fameux
pioncer 4 et on peut pas protéger par
des 5 à cause du beauf ou en fille
enquêteurs c'est comme ça qu'on appelle
le fou qui se développe derrière sa
petite muraille de pions donc coup
suivant classique et un véronique oui
les noirs elles vont jouer c'est simple
c'est simple pour une simple et bonne
raison d'un pour encore une fois
contester la domination blanche au
centre
c'est un coup de libération si les
coupes blanc prennent bien les noirs
pourront se développer tout en reprenant
le pion jour tout simplement fou prend
ses seins
on pourrait d'abord changer l'humeur est
changé d'âme d'abord sur ce n'est pas
une bonne opération pour les blancs et
en un gros pions de plus difficile à
reprendre une attaque le pion avec de
l'élan du thunder ok c'est pas
extraordinaire non pour les blancs c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est pas bon du
tout alors donc là donc effectivement
c'est ça qui est très fort c'est un très
bon coup attaques ont protégé par le fou
et les blancs peuvent pas prendre donc
ils sont sous pression et blanc 1 grâce
à son cou
très très bon donc là les blancs en fait
vont lâcher le pied en d4
et voilà on échange de quoi ils
accélèrent le développement puisqu'il
joue cavalier à 3 donc ils profitent du
fait qu'on peut toujours pas jouer mais
celles qui causent toujours pareil du
fou g2 qui attaquent la torah minh khai
à 3 on profite du fait que ces cinq
étaient jouées qui empêche faut prendre
cavaliers et on veut simplement aller
gobeil qui ont ces quatre avec deux
cavaliers bien placé au centre mais au
prix du pion des 4 on va voir ça tout de
suite après c'est prendre etc la tribune
en cavalier prend s'éclate
voilà donc on a donné ce pion mais alors
qu'un contrôle la case de 5 ça c'est
important je pense alors je suis pas un
expert de cette ouverture mais il faut
contrôler quand même la case
5 parce qu'il faut empêcher les nord de
consolider leurs pions des caps dans ce
cas là c'est un pion qui en plus mais
qui est quand même isolé oui donc il
peut faire office de pression des blancs
qui pourront sans doute le reprendre
plus tard centraux difficulté si le
besoin s'en fait sentir
voilà il faut empêcher que les noirs
consolide avec une chaîne de pion par
exemple sergueev six et ils ont un gros
plus
et puis essayer de contrarier le
développement des noirs bien sûr qui est
quand même peu évident puisque le
cavalier peut pas sortir en c6 on peut
pas ajouté cécile fouan 17 non plus aux
gens prise d'intervalle y ait ensuite
sous prend avec échec et la tour 1 prise
difficile de se développer pour
l'instant de paul-eric pour les noirs
bons qu'ils peuvent comme le jouet le
suivant le coup suivant pardon ou c5
bien fait on protège qui ont des quatre
on sort le fou qui pourront plus venir
l'an dernier à 7 donc avoir une case de
repli tout en gardant un oeil sur ce
pion de plus quand même mon attention et
on a quand même donné un pion en échange
d'un développement rapide et on prépare
le petit rock mais on va voir on voit
bien qu'on va avoir un problème de
développement de ce côté là à cause de
ce magnifique sous g2 qui empêche
beaucoup de développement harmonieux de
se faire du côté noir petit rock la part
des blancs tranquilles on continue les
blancs en développement fassent ils ont
rarement nord petit rock food et 2 alors
ça c'est d'un joli coup de développement
alors non je vous parle tout est simple
parce qu'en fait probablement que
les noirs auraient pu répondre par h si
ces puits ou valve fou parce qu'on peut
pas venir angers 4 à cause de g5 la
folie prix achi c'est peut-être un
couple ayant envie de jouer donc c'est
pas la peine de leur donner en temps de
plus on n'a pas envie d'échanger un fou
non plus contre un cavalier pas ce que
ça donnerait la paire de fou noir
on avait besoin de plus ça commence à
faire beaucoup et donc on le joue ce
quand même sur une case intéressante où
il est souple ce fou puisqu'il continue
à contrôler évidemment les cases de ce
côté là ce qui peut être utile et
regarde de l'autre côté en même temps et
il regarde de l'autre côté du rhin elle
dame il faut observer que cause du coup
à six il ya une petite faiblesse des
noirs sur case noire aura exactement
et si le fougueux pouvait s'emparer 7 de
la diagonale à cinq des huit en
attaquant la namsa sera pas forcément
une mauvaise opération
bien sûr d'autant plus que le cavaly c4n
au contrôle de ses 15,5 éviter à la fois
ils contrôlent la case vous pourrez
venir et aussi la casse b6 donc alors
attention c'est pas c'est pas évident
donc on pourrait profiter d'un
affaiblissement qui ont peu en libère
toujours la fameuse case c1 pour la tour
bien sûr qui est une alors ça c'est dû
au développement mais sûr parce qu'on
l'a développé fou en libère at on donc
encore passation du pillon sacrifié par
les blancs qui ont des cadres
regardez toujours le problème des noirs
manque de développement
donc en fait c'est l'exact cette partie
l'exact opposé aux et de la première
partie où mais en fait c'était le top en
face est la même la même première partie
que vous l'avez première partie du pour
les blancs en fait c'est pas le même
joueur elles souhaitaient topalov la
première valenciennes en sacrifice de
pions les charges d'une initiative donc
la typique des grands joueurs on n'a pas
peur donne un peu de matériel contre de
l'initiative calais des sacs et des cinq
jours ni coups ici qu'il est simple
pourquoi et bien regarder parce que hein
alors évidemment le bouche-trou j'ai
deux châssis pour m utiles les puits 2b
on a parlé de ces quasiment invincible
essayer de réparer donc là sont des fous
sur des fous à 5 et bien on sera quand
même un peu moins embêté de
de la classe b 6 puisqu'on aura quand
même un contrôle supplémentaire grâce
aux cavaliers tour c'est un tranquille
pour lui alors attention on peut les
voir des menaces maintenant puisque dès
que le père et les bouges le foot
attaquer les bouges le foot attaquer
donc calais 17 relais noir bon pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de menace directe
donc aller 17 pour les noirs voilà le
développement logique on ira en
développement possible le câble ace
développe propose déjà un échange de
pièces qui soulagerait sans doute les
wang parce que le camp qui est lequel
moins d'espacé toujours soulagé par les
échanges puisque forcément ça lui libère
de l'espace donc là les blancs n'ont pas
spécialement intérêt à échanger leurs
cavaliers ou cinq contrôles cavaliers
ont 17
bien sûr donc les blancs veulent garder
un maximum de pièces quand on a un peu
moins de matériel évidemment il faut
garder un maximum de pièces il joué le
moins de matériel contre eu une activité
plus forte donc regarder si très
intéressant ce qui va se passer
maintenant donc validé trois menace
réellement de prendre le fou des cas
depuis le fou des deux pourra jouer par
exemple en a 5 et le pion des 4 va être
en prise le problème ils devraient
véritablement attention et aussi la
paire de fou parce que si on prend le
fou c 'est qu' il ya de fous des deux et
j'ai deux contre un seul est le pion de
moins comme un ca d'un grave puisque la
paire de fou ça vaut souvent on dit sa
voiture ont donc attention la paire de
fou alors on dit qu'on a la paire de fou
quand on soi même on a les deux fous et
pas l'adversaire oui que si on est deux
à voir la paire de fou c'est pas tout ça
à dire ça s'équilibre ne peux pas dire
qui est le père de fou il ya une paire
de faux qui se neutralisent alors fou à
donc ça on en avait parlé déjà bon voilà
une belle case 1 d'où l'intérêt de quoi
6 aussi c'est qu'on a quand même une
belle place une sympathique ce fou pour
l'instant alors c'est quand même fou qui
est passif oui même si le pion des
quatre quand même avancé il est bien etc
mais il est bien bloquée sous cavaliers
detroit est magnifique
ce serait bien ce pion et contrôle des
cas toujours un super cavaillé bloqueurs
et donc voilà ce qui se passe alors ici
x 5 seller et les blancs seraient bien
contents que les blancs les noirs jouent
b6 puisque ça affaiblir et un peu ab
cette diagonale on pourrait envisager
plus tard pourquoi pas des faux prend
des cinq ans doublant les pions aussi
maintenant plus tard mais surtout ça
affecterait les cases blanches donc la
place et 6 mai notamment avec un
cavalière de celles qu'on pourrait venir
avec la tour qui contrôle aussi la tour
qui contrôlent donc une pénétration
possible ici d'une pièce par exemple un
cavalier regardez ce qu'avait laissé 4
viendraient ensuite en sec et donc sur
b6 on n'aurait pas en fait de véritables
soucis on reviendrait soit sans doute en
d2 tranquillement et on fait on aurait
gagné le fait d'avoir affaibli cette
diagonale et de pouvoir en profiter par
kyle scène qu'elle a laissé six des
choses comme ça donc à l'arcep donc
c'est pourquoi les noirs ne ne joue pas
bessie smith joue dams est regardé comme
les champions font attention de ne pas
affaiblir leur structure depuis on ne
peut pas bouger leurs pions sans en
avoir bien pesé les avantages et les
inconvénients et en l'occurrence ici
plutôt les inconvénients
c'est une chose qu'on ne répète jamais
assez les pions sont la seule pièce qui
ne revient pas en arrière donc une fois
que le bio est poussée c'est pour toute
la partie
exactement c'est une décision
bouget lourd de conséquences et une
activité responsable et on l'a déjà dit
souvent sur diagonale tv ses
responsables en dame b 3 regardez donc
on sort la dame
donc ça c'est bien et on libère aussi
une case pour la course assez bien on
lit les tours donc on pourra aussi
envisager les tours ces deux suivis de
tours en c1 pour doubler les tours ont
redoublé tour des pour faire pression et
pénétrer plus facilement sur les
colonnes les tours se protégeant
mutuellement et donc on a aussi une
activité sur la soupe cette colonne
tombé huit rapports de topalov alors
tombé huit belles idées aussi c'est que
la dame b 3 commence à faire pression
sur blaise est peut-être plus tard si on
veut bouger le fossé 8
on a intérêt à protéger ceux qui
rentrent en plus en venant à 8
eh bien on se sort de cette fameuse
diagonale un peu pénible alors problème
quand même et on est vite c'est que on
avait une quinzaine fou qui quand même
un fou qui l'a peu de cases les le
développement noir est étriqué oui parce
que ce fou on pourrait aussi envisager
plus tard de le mettre en dvi et de
bouger mais l'a pour l'instant bon il y
en a sept membres s'est passé pas très
grave mais il faut communauté comprend
une case au fond or la trique country
curieux d'un homme est finalement
peut-être bien joué quand même 900
bijoux évidemment pas dire quand on joue
mal c'est pas la question mais un coup
étonnant damas 3 alors vraiment un coup
étonnant
puisque les noirs ne se gênent pas ici
alors il faut regarder la suite pourquoi
donc jusqu'où nommé trois faut regarder
la suite puisque les noirs évidence se
gênent pas d'un prend et on prend avec
doublage on apprend toujours qu'il faut
pas doubler ses pions en avant ne faut
pas tomber si blanc est là et la halde
propose de changer d'âme est en fait un
homme a voulu finalement transposer dans
une finale puisque on a changé les dates
et les finales un peu technique où
l'avion - mais là la colonne ouverte
comme inertes et l'adversaire à des fous
passif mais là ça fonce et 8 joue pas il
est bloqué ce x 7 et pacifique puisque
il tape sur ce pion et finalement les
blancs ont une case centrale cnvdt
associe de fer fou prendre d'essai
qu'avec un doublement un des pions sans
trop noire qui pourrait sans doute
ensuite être pris ensuite on peut
envisager aussi des cavaliers des six
pour prendre ans et 8 et prend la paire
de fou donc la carène possibilités
techniques pour rentrer dans les finales
favorable malgré ses pions le doublé
alors autre avantage aussi avoir doublé
les pions c'est qu'on a ouvert la
colombe et vous être un un terrifiant
scipion ils sont doublés mais finalement
ils font quand même feront face aux deux
pions l'a acquis pour passer devant
quand même passé les deux de toute façon
voilà ils sont difficilement attaquable
par les noirs donc voilà ce qu'a jugé en
inde et il n'a pas eu peur de doubler
ses pions mais c'est quand même un coup
de champion mais on vous conseille pas
oui ça c'est pas un peu évident du tout
alors la laïcité aux palois fait sans
doute une faute compositionnel le
meilleur coup ici c'était 100 dos de
jouer le coup qui avait laissé cinq un
coup assez puissant assez fort puisqu'en
fait on va jouer cavale et ses 5 avec
l'idée bien de d'échangés déjà un
premier cavalier ce qui soulagerait
évidemment la défense des noirs puisque
après si on arrive à sion jusqu'à la lie
par exemple en contrôlant la case de 5
en empêchant car les numéros c'est qu'on
pourrait envisager de développer le fou
en 17 puis pourquoi pas 1 à 4
données d'activité à ce fou libérer la
terre est fluide pour gagner en ses vis
à vis de l'air etc
et en plus ce cavalier pourrait aussi
envisager de venir en a quatre une case
aussi qui peut être intéressante pour
les noirs albi ce que derrière on a
aussi un support trois forces et les
noirs et les blancs apprendre du fou on
libérerait le fou à 7 au prix d'un pion
mais en gagnant la paire de fou on
pourrait changer les avantages et les
avantages de matériel contre un en avant
le talent un nouvel avantage
positionnelle et xavier la position
serait au moins un équilibre dynamique
et positionner exactement leur lieu de
quoi donc topalov joue le coup qui
avalise c'est m6 qui par mauvais mauvais
mais qui quand même un peu passif
puisqu'un hand mais son cavalier en 5 et
disons qu'il a gagné sa bataille une âme
il cavaliere 1,5 et les noirs sont un
peu ficelé quoique faire pas évident
parce que si on bouge donc le pion
toujours pareil endroit femi la casse et
si ce magnifique pour le cabillaud celle
qui fort qui empêchent des
développements 17 simple qui souffre
évidence sur un coup comme cavalier 17
aussi on peut envisager mais fou prend
des 5 avec doublement au centre et les
blancs dans sont régalés à prendre les
pions centre avec toujours la colonne
ouverte au final ils auront un avantage
non pas facile et d'ailleurs topalov
joue derrière d'un des rares coups
possibles tour 8 dont on se demande de
quelle est la véritable idée parce que
tout ruitz écran séparé fuite ou 1,8 à
la pas l'air super active
alors à moins peut-être de vouloir jouer
deux tours 7
pour contrôler la casse et 7 qui peut
être un thème aussi regarder envisager
des fous ses sept plus tard détour c'est
cette hausse ici mais il faut éliminer
ce cavalier mais en attendant tours 8
bon allez peut-être un peu plus actives
comme suit n'est pas beaucoup plus mais
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit un coût
qui prennent l'initiative
ouais c'est pas c'est quand même les
noirs sont très resserrée et la balance
du temps se pressent pas pour ces 2
la doublement par année dont final
technique très instructive les blancs
sont mieux parce qu'ils tiennent le
centre ici avec ce cavalier e st etienne
surtout là que l'on sait et les noirs
sont toujours fermés un peu ils n'ont
pas d'activité et ils sont obligés de
subir et d'attendre mais finalement de
voir ce que les blancs vont faire donc
là blanc et les bleus n'ont pas grand
chose à faire mais les noirs ou encore
moins de choses à faire les voilà c'est
ça c'est que les 900 quasi de veau en
goguette
oui c'est peut-être ça aussi de thèmes
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de là pas vraiment
de coup et enfin jouer à 6 c'est pas bon
ça donne une petite fenêtre au noir mais
on est en finale donc on est bon les
attaques de nattes
c'est pas trop le trot le thème tout de
suite le doublement des tours va arriver
et quand même un plan pour les blancs de
pénétration qui commence à faire deux
jours et il peut y avoir des idées aussi
pour les blancs de jouer g4 pourquoi pas
achetable j'ai cinq attaquants gabriel 6
déstabilisant ce cavalier doublage ici
en dessert et pénétration des tours en
6ème en septième il ya plein d'idées
pour les blancs pour les noirs y en a
pas au bout des six plateaux pas leur
traque un peu oui bon mais il n'a pas
trop le choix
pour lui ce qu'il n'a pas beaucoup de
coups ils essaient de d'abord un peu
d'air et de libérer son foot en baisse
est puisqu'il peut pas le sortir en 17
sous peine de perdre a peur de fonds et
de se faire doubler
il veut essayer de le jouer 17 et des
chevilles et d'essayer finalement des
changes et des taux assez vite donc il
chasse le fou mais après food et de
regarder le problème c'est la casse et
six attaques la tour le x 7 voire 10
fois cette horrible une prisonniers par
sa tour son pion on peut dire de ce x 7
en l'occurrence c'est un groupe ion
c'est un gros pions qui peut qui gênent
plus les noirs qui ne les aide pour
l'instant tout est sûre il pourrait
prendre de la valeur s'il est blanc
dessert un petit peu l'étau mai
une gamme assez peu de possibilités pour
les noirs de se mouvoir dans un petit
espace là encore le thème c'est le
manque d'espacé mouvement le thème si
d'étouffement on s'est vraiment le luxe
du monde par par l'espace l'étouffement
de l'adversaire les noirs sont
extrêmement resserré foulée cette
faillite vicieux pour vos échecs il a
fait mourir à petit feu
c'est terrible alors foot 17 tours fc
est donc la regardent et attendent très
simplement suit son plan abordé donc
très difficile de contester la colonne
alors regardez d'ailleurs c'est crois
que c'est un point c'est un moment
important de la partie oui parce qu'on
imagine simplement que les noirs pour
échanger les tours maintenant ce qui
leur donnerait de l'air non mais la
voilà si les noirs pouvaient jouer tour
s'est vite ça c'est nickel parce que là
bas on échange les tours et la pression
sur la colonne ci n'existe pas en menace
tout reprend pour s'est vite on échange
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe simplement
tout reprend ces 8es par exemple surtout
reprendre tout reprendre vous prendrez
regarder la pointe cavaliers c6 et
regardez c'est le port fois cette île
peut rien faire il est coincé
il est coincé il peut regarder le cas à
les contrôler les deux places du fou il
se fout non on ne peut pas le protéger
par un camion pour rien fait on perd une
pièce donc c'est quand extraordinaire
d'avoir donc on ne peut pas jouer
pas se libérer faut pas se libérer cette
idée de jouets poupées cette étude ne
marche pas parce que les pièces noires
sont mal placés le x 7 est très mal
placé et l'orgue la topalov joue elle
regardait aussi un coup comme becel bon
pourrait envisager bien sûr b5 alors db5
pour se dire bombay maintenant je me
lasse tour s'est vite et si la même
variante en échange qui avait saisi là
je peux sortir ici sous charles ce genre
de choses sauf que la belle et blanc
jouent qu'avait laissé si c'est après
attaque
tourabi tu fous bessèges et surtout
prend tout reprend alors on commence à
avoir un problème s'ils ont pu ainsi
cela fait les faiblesses sont toujours
là donc avec un deuxième quart aller qui
peut sauter de nouveau sur la créativité
et la pression ne
des cerpa mais c'était quand même
possible d'envisager c'est un an au lieu
de quoi topalov joue ici tour bd 8 mai
tombent et des vite bon on sait pas trop
l'idée signer peut-être joué fou de 8 et
essayer de commencer à contester cette
case de 5 qui est forte tout le doubs
sans doute l'idée d'un an suivant la sur
l'idée suivante danon qui curieuse quand
même parce que moi j'ai pas trop peu au
tofu 8 puisque je contrôle déjà avait le
cas les trois bons alors moi j'avais
dans l'idée est peut-être un peu
curieuse mais de jouer plutôt g4 ici et
sur h 6 h 4 empêcher j'essaye h4 et on
accourt bon c'est pas grave on donne une
un peu le roi certes il n'y a pas de
danger immédiat
voilà on est quand la finale et on n'a
surtout chez celles du pourquoi pas même
g6 derrière et on a déstabilisé ce
cavalier éventuellement on a détruit la
structure du côté noir mancunien on a
aussi détruit en bout la structure de
l'ange mais c'est moins grave côté blanc
parce que
encore une fois les blancs ont
l'avantagé de l'espace ici ouais il
ils ont donné plus d'espacé à la lhdaa
mais pourquoi pas s'arranger un peu plus
d'espacé avait le droit
c'est pas plus pas les blancs que ça
dérangerait le plus effectivement g4 et
h4 c'est un plan qui aurait pu être le
plan d'un land art est un homme plein
donc j'essaye même soi même on n'a pas
bougé de jauger si d'ailleurs puisque le
fou des deux protéines sur câblage 7 on
n'a pas de problème mais on peut
toujours envisager 6 et puis bon mais
surtout une fois que le cavalier sorti
bon ben je veux dire le fou le cadre des
5 aussi à manquer et moins soutenu et on
peut envisager des pénétrations de tours
avec vous prend pour ces sept des choses
comme ça il ya des calculs à faire mais
par exemple sur vous prend vous prend un
tour ces sept on va bien le fou est
attaqué et le purifient cette voie là
donc ça aurait pu faire des thèmes bon
au lieu de quoi on en garde un plan plus
positionnelle mais c'est un cookie qui
assure que les commentateurs aussi quand
même mais f4 donc en fait ils
consolident la classe de ceric et c'est
ce n'est pas le coût qu on conseillerait
dans un cours d'échecs parce que on crée
quand même une caste faible en mai trois
ont créé alors voilà problème on crée
une tasse faire un autre et puis surtout
on a ce qu'on en parle et on ouvre la
diagonale du fou et ces voix là on ouvre
la diagonale il faut sept ans vous direz
le pion des quatre ans pêche met
d'accord mais on peut quand même osé
rêver sel et après on peut envisager des
choses des caillots 3 surtout prendre
puis on prend ce fou de même pénible et
on verra d'ailleurs il ya un petit
thèmes possibles mais finalement
maintenant de calculer que c'était un
bon ben ça reste des telle tactique
auquel il faut faire attention mais ils
sont moins importants que le facteur
positionnelle est le facteur
positionnelle ici c'est de contrôler la
case de seuils et d'empêcher a dit à mme
eternal j'ai envie de dire de noir de
protéger leurs pions des caps par une
autre pion par le pion de 6 c'est fini
ça pourra jamais être possible dans le
bios f4 veille les deux cavaliers le
périph 4 la classe de 5 et solidement
défendu
donc c'est un coup aussi prophylactique
positionnelle food évident quand même
pour les noirs benoît tente de faire
petite pression sur la cage de scène
commençait alors autre idée qui peut
suivre un prix aussi c'est d'envisager
pourquoi pas des qualités celles aidées
f6 pour chasser ce cavalier le segment
mais c'est long et en attendant alain
dejoux d'être joli coup donc ces deux
pions là vous plaît les joueurs en
général non plus lui conseille pas fait
tout ce qui est pas conseillé il fait
tout ce qui est pas conseillé c'est en
général la marque des champions parce
qu'il va bien tout ce qui est des
conseillers et guingamp gagne que oui
mais parce que justement ils le font à
des moments qui sont exceptionnellement
des cas justement c'est possible de le
faire vos qui jouent des pions ou doublé
escompté des conseils en général à 4
mais pourquoi cas très simplement mais
d'avoir peut-être pour l'enlever de
cases noires se payant puisqu'il
n'aurait pu être attaqué par le fou et
aussi parce que ce pion à 4 finalement
tient en respect les deux pions à 6 c b6
des qui bouge mais en déplorant des
doubles finalement les pions et on
affaiblit le
le pion des cinq donc ce pion tient en
respect ses deux pions qui doivent
rester la lorelei topaloff est sans
doute une deuxième je n'irai faute après
lequel il joue à 5 alors à 5 c'est pas
bon on se demande ce que vient faire le
point 5
ils contrôlent akasbi cadre peut-être
son idée à topalov s'était joué tout bd
6 et de contrôler la casse mais qu'a
donc devenir après mais lecavalier en b
4 de ramener le deuxième cavaliers sauf
que c'est très difficile d'envisager ça
puisque le fou g2 empêche
oui le kyle busch est donc cette idée de
contre la casse b4 elle affaiblit
surtout le casque p5 elle a fait briller
le pion à 5 on va voir aussi que ça va
être crucial dans la suite de la partie
donc c'est pas un coup super super était
pas en forme qu'à spa qu on peut se
demander si topalov a pas finalement un
peu trop arrosé sa victoire récompense
je pense que quand quelqu'un qui boit le
vin d'honneur qui descend - alcool local
très fort justement on n'est pas loin de
la grèce ça doit être quelque chose de
très fort mais en l'occurrence peut-être
que cette première victoire dans la
première partie est venue trop
rapidement pour lui et que il a
peut-être pas sous-estimer nantes bien
sûr mais peut-être qu'il sert aux il ya
un relâchement coupable ou
psychologiquement il a peut-être cru que
ça serait plus facile que oui c'est ça
c'est peut-être relâché suite à la
victoire facile ça se fera cette partie
il avait l'air ou alors simplement
attendent à très bien jouer
psychologiquement en amenant topalov sur
le type de position peut finalement il
appareille
où il apparaît que topalov a des soucis
c'est pas trop comment les traiter
qu'avait laissé six noms par dc lors
pourquoi qu'elle nécessitera des
demandes déjà
j'attaque la tour et le faux buts alors
s'il faut lui tendre j'étais quand même
des problèmes rim et puis en occasion en
or qui sont quand même deviennent très
faibles donc
il ya ça appuie donc y est aussi ont des
cadres tout simplement on a tout
simplement donc là non c'est surtout le
temps des 4e dire là la menace si la
tour bouge on prend le temps des quatre
on en récupère un pur avec une grosse
pression des pions finalement le cube et
6 devient une faiblesse voire dès
maintenant qu'on a joué à 5 peut plus
jouer en bessin du tout et on met toutes
les pièces sur la colombe et on va finir
par le groupe des champions donc on voit
que ça devient plus un souci est souvent
faible son coût à 5 la paix pas beaucoup
calais c6 donc la coop allophones est
obligé de prendre prend sinon lüthi vers
le plan des quatre il a plus aucune
compensation pour sa position inférieure
les blancs la colonne c'est des pions là
qui sont faibles final plus faible que
les prix ont doublé
on du fait qu' ils sont comme ça puis en
arriérés et sur une colonne bon c'est
pas bon donc je prends ces 6es mais on
donne à perdre au foot tout de suite
pour prince et six paires de fouet donné
on va voir que les noirs vont réussir à
la récupérer mais à quel prix on n'aime
pas voir regarder cette super regarder
un peu plus vers assez vite c'est fini
donc avec le foot bechet on pourrait
bien être armés
maintenant c'est possible mais c'est
fini cette colonne vaut largement un
pion plus la paire de fou et même le
pion des mois j'ai estimé la boj estime
que les blancs soit un peu mieux et plus
de facilité de jeu risque pas de perdre
et les noirs n'ont toujours pas de plan
pas les noirs ont pas de plainte c'est
extrêmement passif et ils sont en
attente h5 topalov qui se donne un peu
d'air
alain le roy et blanc vont consolider
tranquillement regarder avec de très
jolis coups suivants simple mais joli
tour ces quatre pays sont dj menace tout
simplement de reprendre le pion aux
ménages pour prendre des quatre et que
font les noirs pas évident de trouver un
coup pour ce cavalier six cas les bouges
par exemple en deux sets c'était un v6
quittera incliné topalov tout le seul
coup et qui est un bon coup que hollande
avait sans doute évidemment calculés
cavaliers 3 et alain ne va rendre la
paire de fou pourquoi parce que là
regardez il ya quand même fourchette est
en fait un nom ne veut pas fourchette
ici on ne veut pas perdre de temps déjà
s'ils ajoutent des quatre c'est pas pour
revenir et puis veut pas non plus donné
son feu rouge et deux parce qu'ils
estiment qu'il est supérieur aux fous v8
qui lui est passif après fou prend en 3d
prend 1,3 regardez simplement
alors si jolie se pressent pas à l'homme
de prendre pied au brésil pourrait
maintenant il faut d'abord garder faute
fou et le froid il consolide le pion aux
deux et puis les jette un oeil sur le
sur ce plan je sais qu'il empêche calais
des cinq pour protéger plan b si ce sont
les punis par comprend cinq donc c'est
simplement un coup intermédiaire presque
au coude attentes qui force le coup
suivant quasiment ne peut pas loger six
ont protégé avec un pion qu'on libère
ses cavaliers aux menaces de venir dès 5
ans 17 protéger le pont b6 et regarder
l'idée pour prendre des vessies ce hélas
topalov joue le joli c'est joli quand
même attention x 7 et la piège bien un
piège
attention parce que si la tour se retire
sur
la colonne un peu n'importe quoi rayon
des singles gober le pion voilà petit
piège et là on avait déjà dit qu'on a
mais on n'avait pas trop le coup et 4
parce que regarder le fou fait presque
échec pardon dit et ça c'est pas une
bonne de bonal le fou fait presque échec
aura blanc et le presque mais il devient
possible si l'on sacrifie la toux en d3
on va voir exactement cercle là si les
noirs jouent simple allez nord peuvent
jouer tout reprendre garder la pression
prendre garde et maintenant ça devient
possible de bouger surtout le pion le
pion et sur échec alors c'est mortel
le roi ne peut pas venir en f1 pour
attaquer le pion ni en f2 puisqu'il ya
le fou et il est en échec
il faut jouer par exemple moi j'ai deux
et hauts faits d'armes alors si horrible
d'arrière voilà donc un an n'aurait
abandonné cette position donc piège
donc attention à nantes prend ici mais
évidemment il a vu le piège et surtout à
cette annonce
tranquillement il aurait pu jouer aussi
sans doute tour bessette puisque sur
trop plomber 3 il aurait fait tout
reprend à 7 et non papillon 30 trouver
sur voilà la possibilité qu'il aurait pu
avoir mais à nantes joue encore plus à
un peu être plus solide sans doute aussi
pour détroit et il protège de cavaliers
avec la tour donc en cas de toux reprend
on prend pas évidemment avec les pions à
cause de l'échec mais on prend avec la
tour et on a consolidé la position donc
final très intéressante pour b3 et là
alors topaloff est sans doute alors sa
dernière non son avant-dernier rire
alors il n'est fait beaucoup d'erreurs
on avait vu qualif 6 qui était pas au
moins fort que câbles nécessaires à 5 et
à 5 était douteuse faiblissement était
déjà effectivement sous pression mais
bon c'était quand même affaiblie siens
et alors là l'erreur final est sans
doute parce qu'il n'a pas vu et qui va
se passer autour des 4 or il ne te parle
c'est simple dit mais si la tour bouge
je prends à 4 simplement il ne peut pas
prendre un 4 parce que il ya poussé 6 et
voilà
qui a sacré les deux tours il n'a pas vu
il n'a pas vu mais l'idée de tableau si
celle-ci la tombe où je prend 1,4 et
donc tu es obligé prendre et je soulage
ma position je suis content d'avoir eu
souvent des cas parce que si tu attaques
et b5 je peux jouer sous ses trois puits
fou des deux jeux consolide mais deux
pions et après j'ai une position
finalement pas si mal mais il
mais non pas du tout regardé andy n'a
pas peur ils jouent pour ses sets et
l'offre le pion y est imprenable
voilà pour le foie pas de kazan c5
évidence est impossible de cavalia tour
faux b6 pas possible à cause de la tour
donc un seul coup possible to b vite et
là regardez simplement tour ses cinq
essais finit par ne récupère le plus
ancien qu'on peut dire déjà que les
blancs sont sont déjà gagnants je pense
à vous le dire ici surtout rang à 4
regardez simplement nom de rejouer
pouces et 6 gagner le tour
c'est même pas une qualité c'est une
tournette c'est une tournette avec
massacre derrière donc c'est pas
possible
donc c'est ce cap sans doute à oublier
topalov vraiment le coup faire le tour
des classes en venant ce qui lui a pris
on gagne une tournette pour une bonne
raison
c'est parce que la tour 8es les protégés
par le cavalier oui on qui sur wii mais
oui alors un peu oui on peut voir
surtout reprend à calais face à 6 pouces
et 6 par exemple tout reprend à deux on
a une tournette à cause de supra ankara
les prends mais tu tombé 80 au v8 sa
venue le cavalier mais le cavalier
derrière avec tours s'est vite on s'est
vite et on gagne le clavier donc ça
donne beaucoup trop ça vient de tout
tout le matériel tout le magasin
c'est trop cher le magasin food et 6
donc de topalov est évidemment tout
reprend 1,5 donc là attention les blancs
sont très bien on peut dire qu'ils sont
un million de plus matériellement mais
presque deux pions même si c'est des
pions doublé ce sont quand même des
pions passé et depuis on passait ici des
pions pas s'est éloigné en plus qui
menacent de filer à dame et quand on
peut même en sacrifier un il restera
encore un alors que le pion ici on a
quatre pions contre 5 mai ses lectures
d'oubli quiberon même s'il est un peu
pénible seppi en trois ses parents non
dangereux parce qu'on voit pas comment
les noirs peuvent attaquer les blancs
sur casse blanche a pris corps
le roi noir peut toujours s'en fuir n'y
a pas de réseau de maintien pas de croix
blanche voilà n'y a pas de réseau de
maths clair et c'est quand même beaucoup
de mes pions les pions blancs sur la
colonne 1 vont en théorie aller jusqu'à
la case à 8
ouais et il ya le fou qui exemplaires
vendus qui les soutient et ça c'est très
important d'avoir un tout
et oui et contrôler la caisse de
promotion bien sûr le plus on va aller à
1,8 et les noirs ne peut même pas
opposer une pièce une tour en général
comme il a eu des non c'est pas possible
donc c'est très très difficile d'arrêter
l'avancée des plan va le voir après tour
s'est vite de topalov simplement rangés
deux tours ces deux bons ils activent
quand même sa tour attention maintenant
le pion ici est cloué faudrait pas à
jouer tour bouge puisque tourcoing
cavaliers serait joué dans l'un des
plats bête il va pas livré le voir il va
pas le jouer
attention quand même aussi on va pas
donner gratuitement le pion à 2 et
regarder sort c'est très joli à 3 et là
encore une erreur d'autres de par leurs
élites lagarde et m
la dernière aura deux vraiment là la
dernière erreur c'était pas évident de
trouver un preneur de côté pas évident
de trouver un coup alors peut-être tour
ce tour c'est 4 peut-être ces quatre
auraient été envisageables mais c'est
con tu disais c'est très difficile
d'arrêter le pion qui va 1,8 avec le
faux estran qui contrôlent puisqu'on
peut mettre la torah 8 pouces et 1 à 7
et enfin un échec on fait quand même
dame derrière avec le foot qu'ils
contrôlent c'est très difficile donc tu
auras 2 et regardez là simplement notre
super beaucoup d'un homme tranquille
calais b 4 et le coup à deux est un tour
à la torah de est un coup dans l'eau
parce qu'on peut pas re tour avec l'idée
d'amener la deuxième tour faire un échec
qui posait peut-être des problèmes
tout simplement parce que surtout rade
maintenant il ya les vidant cavaliers
des quatre fourchette encore une
fourchette à croire que topalov nouveau
prochainement ce match non mais il a
trop bu la veille
n'oubliez découvert la maison via le
souss et si ce qu'ils voient pas non et
là à croire qu'il donne le bâton pour se
faire battre
les voiles domlebo double c'est très
curieux qui il a l'air vraiment en
dessous dans cette partie très en
dessous chaos db4 problèmes et leurs
hommes plus jeunes ce cavalier regarder
pendant toute la partie il a bloqué la
colonne débit donc empêché l'étonnante
pénétrer un notamment attendait cava
peut pas pénétrer donc et très bien
bloqué ici alors maintenant qu'il vient
bk ils empêchent parce que si on
poussait le pion direct si on avait joué
des tours à huit échecs puis à celle
bateaux des quatre auraient pu venir en
1 4 mais en venant des quatre non
seulement j'attaque la tour je les
propose carrément de revenir en d2 qui
ne remonte pas un succès ça n'a vraiment
pas utile en d2 et en plus j'ai empêche
la tour des quatre devenir un cas donc
je peux pousser le pion à 64 ans qui
n'est bon bah oui sans aucune résistance
possible
magnifique cavalier bloqueurs pendant
toute la partie de sa force quasiment
fond promet 4l regardé comme en inde a
transformé sam alors il a joué très vite
en plus qui on prend les quatre gardés
en a deux pions de passer éloigné avec
une tour en plus derrière le tube est un
fou ici horaires dits qui domine le
cavalier puisque le cavalier est en
prise sur toutes les cases blanches et
roi des corses qui suit car les dessins
au total of simplement bessec
anand sacrifie pion à 4 il faut prendre
une lancinante on n'a plus rien on a des
pions parce qu'ils font ce tour prend à
4 pour prendre quatre tours prend 1,4 et
regardez simplement échanges tranquille
au centre quelle technique magnifique la
simplicité à la kapisa où ils essayaient
de handicap est bloqué chez nous alors
cette perte b6 alors regardez comme bay
comment on fait pour arrêter le pion si
on fait rien les noirs bessette et c'est
fini la tour ne pourra plus venir en a
vite puisque le pion attaquera où tout
de suite venu à 8 pour pouvoir se mettre
en grève 8es avec thank you tout de
suite on aura vite mambé s'est tu quand
même et après web et 8 roi f3 attaque le
pion aux trois jeux menace de tout
ramasser avec le roi la tour étant
bloqué des quatre recadre fini abandon
on peut suivre
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
peut-être pour les noirs pour tenir
encore on peut essayer avec le roi noir
mais d'essayer
il remplace et peut-être la tour ici et
avec la fin c'est extrêmement délicat
mais c'est même pas possible c'est le
roi prend des cas 3e set croire ses 5es
suroît 17 simplement roi v6 l'euro est
coupée on va faire en échec au couple
oratoire roi ses 7es bindum c'est fini
super party bon alors un peu le tournant
c'est quand même assez étonnant parce
que ton pas la face super mais je vous
la veille et la cfm a massacré sur cette
partie il a été il a été étouffé et je
crois que cette situation même pas ce
genre de situation et c'est peut-être
qu'il la met à faire des erreurs des
imprécisions ne pas voir les fourchettes
ne pas voir les les enfilades de neuf ou
sur les tours et c'est peut-être qu'il a
été un peu déstabilisé d'être dans le
rôle du défenseur alors alors qu'il
avait qu'il préfère être dans un rôle
plus offensif ce qu'on peut noter
peut-être je remets ça peut-être thème
du match qu'il faut noter c'est que
cramique avait battu topalov il l'avait
battu en jeu à la catalane
oui donc on peut considérer peut-être
que à ne repose le même problème à
topalov bon mais tu fais tes fait battre
proprement par kramnik à la catalane
qu'est ce que tu as prévu et bien
apparemment il s'est toujours pas ceint
dit pas tout y est voilà ce qui se passe
on en a repris larmes de cramique contre
autres pas l'offre avec les blancs et ça
lui pose un gros problème mais pour
l'instant effectivement ça donne raison
à l'inde parce que on n'a pas vu de
préparation chez topalov qui soit
visiblement efficace contre la catalane
puisque dès les premiers coups il a été
un peu sur le reculoir et la situation
n'a cessé d'empirer jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'issue avec ce curieux damas trois oui
c'était très curieux
en même temps là c'est un coup de
champion ça c'est un coup de facto le
rôle magnifique doublage de pions mais
cette pression continuelle de la partie
sur la partie par anand colonne c'est
cette histoire de père de fou cette
histoire de pions fait mais de
pénétration est devenue une
simplification à la fin qui est
magnifique
beau château un angle chapeau attendent
et topalov alors voir maintenant comment
le match va suivre si si on met ko la
veille à nandy revient le lendemain
c'est lui qui met ko c'est un match qui
démarre très fort ça a c'est un beau
match pour l'instant c'est un très beau
match avec deux très belles parties bien
merci je rentre pour cette deuxième
partie même si tu fais un plaisir et
bien pour la suite des partis on aura
d'autres invités puis je crois que tu
vas revenir pour la suite du match un
peu plus tard pour les parties 7,8 je
crois je sais plus si on arrive jusque
là on espère que la décision soit pas
fait non je pense que ça va se jouer aux
alentours de la partie cette suite avec
un peu de chance
voilà merci à tous de nous suivre sur
les gones al tv et puis je joue aux
échecs
c'est bon pour pour le mental et pour le
physique que c'est pour le physique liée
au physique aussi ça vous permet d'être
concentré même quand on fait du sport
voilà merci au revoir à bientôt à
bientôt